raconte ça s'est excusé moi aujourd'hui
lever le pied sur le style son luxe et
bon débarras
alors oui et donc moi une fois je
m'étais fait opérer les cheveux ou sa
vie à deux ans maintenant vous paierez
deschamps s'est fait prélever chapeau on
peut enlever le chapeau oui bien sur wii
et que ça coûte cette histoire ça coûte
ça dépend du nombre de cheveux qui est à
mettre mais ça coûterait à lui l'idée
moi c'est parce que c'est comme vous
maîtrisez cheveux sont implantées en
fonction d'implantation donc on mets les
plus fins devant les plus l'épée
derrière mais la plantation ça change
beaucoup la plantation naturel c'est un
vrai boulot c'est l'artisanat mais est
donc enfin bref voilà donc 50 dollars
hier entre 6000 et 10 1012 mélange entre
les cheveux ça dépend vous ça coûterait
rien pratiquement qualité capillaire est
ce que tu veux ajouter là ça fait trop
de poids la langue avant goût plus la
guerre à gaza
merci non et alors vous allez voir le
surnom que vous ont trouvé les bodin's
d'ailleurs anne hathaway alors ah bah je
crois que vouliez pub alors quand je
m'étais fait opérer les cheveux et
j'avais eu ce qu'on appelle un oedème
savez si on a un thème ou qui gonfle
terriblement message avait remarqué wii
possède ça j'avoue j'avais c'était très
gonflé j'avais de l'eau sous la peau et
ça très bon reflet et j'habite à un peu
blafard sud et quelqu'un m'a appelé jean
luc dans la rue pour cgt jean luc
lemoine au nom
c'est catastrophique
vous riez ou six mois ces bruits et
soutien et sortez pas ça souvent
il faut qu'ils restent là qu'ils vivent
avec sa honte
[Rires]